Your red blood cells are the life givers. They
carry oxygen to all the nooks and crannies of
your body in exchange of the waste product carbon
dioxide. Now hemoglobin is the actual protein molecule responsible
for directly binding the oxygen inside your red blood
cells. And if we exclude water, hemoglobin makes up
over 95% of all the cellular protein inside red
blood cells. Now hemoglobin itself is actually a superstructure
of multiple proteins. And mutations in any
one of the individual protein sub-units has the
potential to cause serious problems. Affecting one of
the most fundamental processes necessary for survival. The
supply of oxygen. One of the most important
proteins, hemoglobin beta is encoded by the HBB
gene. Now in humans, HBB can be found
on the 11th chromosome in the human genome.
Now, chromosome 11 is about 134 million base
pairs long and the HBB gene can be found
somewhere close to the end of it. Now the
HBB gene itself consists of three exons spanning 1,700
base pairs of DNA. This is actually kind
of small in comparison with some of the other
genes we've looked at. After transcription and splicing, the
resulting mRNA has 444 nucleotides of coding region between
the start and stop codons. And after translation, we
get a protein with 147 amino acids. Remember we
just divided 444 by 3, the number of nucleotides
in a codon. And then subtracted that number by
1 to get 147 because the last stop codon
doesn't have an amino acid, it's just empty. Now
as you can imagine this HBB protein, haemoglobin beta
is pretty important and so that any changes could have
a drastic effect on the overall function of the
protein. There was one quite famous allele of the
HBB gene that ultimately changes the structure of hemoglobin
and the red blood cell, thus causing sickle cell anemia.
Now this particular allele contains an A to T
mutation, an adenine to thymine mutation, at position 20 of
the coding region. So using the genetic code that we
learned about in lesson three and which you can find
in the instructor's notes on this page. I want
you to determine the change in the expected amino acid
sequence from the adenine to the thymine position, and then
select the type of mutation that's best used to describe
the T-allele from the list here. If you have
any trouble answering this, just review mutations from lesson six.